I feel like you were the first guy that
really started talking about what was
going on behind the behind those magical
headsets I said they're magical headsets
because you put them on and everything
you accomplished over the course last 15
years it's disappeared there was a girl
named a female wrestler Layla remember
yeah sure well and when I returned to WB
after some time off she was like
cowering backing away she was terrified
of me why and I think she would say that
I was like the meanest person she'd ever
seen fair based on one interaction she
observed with me and mr. McMahon where I
did not take well to being cursed at on
the headset you know oh and she just
happened to be there I just I just
snapped you know I snapped and I don't
you talk to me that way ever again he's
not at him stop - mr. McMahon Wow
and so then it was like and then it was
like three years later or the same
finger that was like wagging in his face
was dialing the phone and going okay and
how was it how was um same finger huh
how was no it's probably one over
actually how was a mr. McMahon when you
called mr. McMahon actually been a year
and a half since we've spoken and I got
a message on the phone and he was like I
know you don't like me but I know you
love this company there was there was a
time when they I guess people were bad
mouth from the company he wanted me to
weigh in on you know my feelings and I
called him back and I went I live in sin
he goes I make us I like you like I do
deep down I really I like him he didn't
like being smoked I didn't like that job
it wasn't the right job for me like I
was I was a pat in the back guy and not
a kick in the butt you know and I didn't
deal well with that but that's uh and I
don't know like about I've talked to
other broadcasters and no one else goes
through that but he's just such a he
cares so much about every aspect
of the product you know that because in
my mind like you you're not calling what
you see in the ring you're calling me to
see on the monitor like you've got to
get into that role where everything you
see there becomes real you know and it's
similar like when I'm say going into my
new book saying man that's a great book
yes what I'm when I have a visit like
with and I'm not talking so much about
the long lines but like a hospital visit
or Charlotte and where you have some
time with a child like you get into that
character to the point where you like
you feel like you're the guy you know
and that's the biggest because they want
the character to get the cat well the
kids yeah I mean you know the kids most
of the time they go I mean you see it in
every movie like all right I know you
work for him like in home alone like how
it works you know so the highest form of
flattery this is when I started
volunteering for group called Christmas
magic they called me in I to do their
the the guy had found in this charity
after 30 years he had rotator cuff
surgery couldn't do any lifting so he
asked me if I would take over his role
and I felt like I was being called in
from the bullpen you know for the
seventh game of the World Series and so
I went here and these are the kids and
you know homeless shelters and foster
insurance and so I went there and I go
all out you know it's the beard and
whatever mannerism you like Christmas
there are snow cones on your shirt you
know I do a little Santa hits another
event social workers going do you know
what the children were saying on the bus
and I said no what they were they were
going that was the real Santa and it was
like the greatest compliment you know
like sure that's the biggest compliment
so like I going back but that's like you
know you're here with that your child
you're telling these stories that you
know that you've come up with you're
trying to make this best experience if
somebody's in your head phone yelling at
you yeah taking you out of that world it
would be really